it was truly just a an honest mistake
that went out in in typing the email
field we've got a tweet here from the
New York Post we're going to Boston
Boston mayor Michelle woo shows off
photo from electeds of color holiday
party after defending Gathering a
special moment so look at that table the
mayor of Boston that woman right there
Michelle woo who appears to be Asian and
generally speaking uh the woke mind
virus is not too friendly to Asian
people uh there she is having a special
Gathering of people of color it's it's
if if I said there's a whole table full
of colored people there people would say
that that's racist but they call they
had a dinner and they said it's the
electeds of color anyway she has had a
long history of doing this kind of
nonsense it's actually crazy that we
haven't done more videos about this
woman but here she is defending her her
holiday party without white people given
some of the Strife that exists though in
this Council you concern this lens
itself at all to further
divisiveness no I mean um again this is
a a a group that has been in place for
many many years we want to be a city
where everyone's identity is embraced
and that there are spaces and
communities that we can help support oh
there are spaces and communities that we
can help support so we can look at a
bunch of people by their skin color and
say Don't eat with us don't come to this
dinner party that's what we used to call
racism you might know that back in the
day when we were having the Civil Rights
Movement black people wanted to get into
say white country clubs and there was a
bunch of white people that said we want
to have our own white spaces and they
were known as the racists back in the
day that's what you people would call
the white supremacists of our day if a
bunch of white people wanted to have
dinner with no colored people as you
call them you'd call them racist so it's
racist whichever way way it goes but she
continued I think we've we've had
individual conversations with everyone
so people understand that it was truly
just a an honest mistake that went out
in in typing the email field and um I
look forward to celebrating with
everyone at the holiday parties that we
will have besides this one as well so um
it is my intention that we can again um
be a city that lives our values and
creates space for all kinds of
communities to come together she saying
everything at and nothing at once right
we should have parties for everybody we
had this party for the colors we'll have
some other parties for some other people
it was a typo like these people are just
absolutely worthless and we have put
them into the system they're not
worthless they are useful idiots she
strikes me as a useful idiot I don't
know who is pulling the strings behind
her she doesn't seem particularly bright
and it's like lady you're racist now you
if you imagine if you're just a white
guy in Boston you're Larry Bird you're
wandering why wouldn't you Larry Bird
why wouldn't you invite Larry Bird to
your Boston dinner party that's
everybody's dream to have in Boston to
have dinner with Larry Bird give me
another give me a hockey player up in
Boston who Tom Tom Brady Tom Brady Tom
Brady give me a couple more Boston white
people we got Larry Bird Tom Brady Bill
bich Bill bellich do we have anyone not
involved in sports in Boston oh what
about Ted Danson from cheers that was in
Boston Conor give me something here I I
always turn to you for white references
give me one more one more a hockey
player from Boston uh I don't watch
hockey Bill bur Bill Burr is he from
Boston he's a comedian we're told he's
from Boston okay anyway that would be a
great white dinner I would enjoy that
dinner anyway um Michelle woo I want to
throw back to something during Co so you
remember our summer of love when black
lives matter was rampaging through
everything antifa and in the name of
Tolerance and diversity that were
burning down stores and beating people
and all that uh here she is during those
riots warning people about white
supremacy across the Boston Police
Department the uh Transit Police the
state police the FBI and all of our
partners in law enforcement and Public
Safety there is constant communication
about the impending um actions of any
known groups we continue to monitor the
situation and to work closely with
community members most of all we want to
ensure that community members are
empowered in uh communicating anything
that you may see or hear or um read
about on social media to to please air
on the side of reaching out to local
public safety officials so that we can
have the most information at hand and we
will continue to work in partnership
with community members as we strategize
and plan and coordinate um to respond to
not oneoff incidents but this growing
ride and Trend in white supremacy yes
because you do remember all of the white
people in the name of reigning Supreme
who were burning down all of the
buildings it's all nonsense you I know
you guys get it I know you get
it